This is Jocko podcast number
61 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good Evening Echo. Good me.
So it's been a few episodes
since we got into the Q and.
A.
I'm sure.
So today we're gonna go right
into questions that come,
they actually come from the
interwebs. Sure. People out there.
So everyone that's gives
questions. Appreciate it.
Thank you for the questions.
I can't answer them all but
talking to some people out there,
if you listen to the different questions
you can figure out your own answers to
a lot of them.
Yeah.
You like learn the formulas
and then you can apply.
But thanks for the questions.
Appreciate it. Sometimes when you,
in my experience anyway, when
I think, okay I'm going to,
I'm going to ask Jocko this question
and then you either write it out or you
didn't.
One I remember the other day when I,
when I busted out questions
and when I say them out loud,
it was like a few weeks ago
and I say it out loud when I'm,
as I'm saying it to you, I'm like, oh,
I know that's already cause you know,
you realize seeking, kind of utilize that
hole. So you've started to get the uh,
formulas in your own head and now
as you're saying and be saying, oh,
I know what the answer. No, yes, exactly.
How do I get out of bed in the morning?
How do I be mentally tougher?
Be Mentally tougher. All right,
rock and roll. First question, go Jocko.
Hydroco today I had what I believe you
referred to as disciplinary breakdown.
This morning I found out that I had to
take additional credits in college and
that I believe were completed.
So he thought they were complete.
He had to take more.
As it turns out in a fit of rage,
I took my phone and threw it
across the room in frustration.
I felt really good at at time,
but five seconds later regretted
it because now broken phone
and I lost control of my emotions.
So do you have any mental
tricks or anything in general
that you do when you're
slightly irritated or outright furious?
Ps,
this used to happen a lot more.
I started to Jitsu and haven't
rolled for three weeks.
Maybe I'm reading too much into it,
but I felt great whenever
I was rolling consistently.
Hmm. Maybe anecdotal. However,
we do know that Jujitsu
soothes the soul. Uh, so,
well, one of the things in mean,
and you've talked about this too,
when I realized that losing your
temper was a sign of weakness.
As soon as I read it, soon as I made
that connection, I said to myself,
this week I'm going to
try not to do it anymore.
And what's weird is when you're a kid,
I don't know if you remember this,
but when I was a kid and you'd see
someone get angry and it made you afraid.
And so for a while I saw it
as like a power, you know,
it's kind of a way to achieve power that
you can lose your temper and then all
of a sudden you have this extra strength.
And so when you're a little kid,
and when I say a little kid, I mean when
I was 1314 years old, I thought, hey,
if I go, if I could get that rage
going, and people are scared,
like I used to feel, that's a
positive thing. And then like I said,
as I got older,
now you know,
now you're talking 1615 1617 I realized,
hey,
this isn't, this isn't cool. This isn't
strength. It's actually a weakness.
And when I realized it was weakness,
and I didn't realize that overnight,
but I started getting the
idea that that was weakness.
And now
when you see someone that is in control,
and even when bad things are
happening there, you know, they're,
they're standing stoically saying,
okay,
let me take another look at that and
I'll get it done. You know what I mean?
When they're just, okay, then you realize,
okay, this guy's really unflappable,
which is a lot more impressive. So again,
you, you gotta be able to
detach from this. And you know,
I like to take pride in the fact that
I'm going to keep my cool no matter what
happens. And definitely once I was in
that, once you're in the seal teams,
you definitely want to be
that guy that's keeping your,
keeping your cool no
matter what's happening,
whether it's people or
doing the wrong thing,
or you just want to be the guy that's,
hey, okay, come back over here.
We need to Redo this.
You just want to be that guy that's way
more impressive than the guy that says,
I can't believe this. Don't
be that person. So, and I've
talked about this before,
and what are the pre event indicators
that show you or revealed to you that your
temper is about to be lost? What are
they? Is it you clench your fist,
right? Is it you raise your voice and
you start doing it, getting that stuff?
Do you start to heavy breathing? Do you
feel you flair your nostrils, right?
Cause that's an animal thing where
you're going to take in more oxygen.
So you open up the nostrils cause you're
about to get after it. Do you, you know,
use your, does your, your head,
you know, shaking or whatever.
You can just like these things.
What is it,
what indicators do you have when you
know that you're starting to feel that?
And as soon as you feel that you
detach, you go, oh, that's what that is.
That's an indicator and it's a weakness.
And I don't like weakness,
so I'm not going to allow it and then
know, take a breath. I
like to say, you know what,
here's a good one. You want to, you
want to get through that, that moment.
Nod your head slowly in the affirmative.
Right? So, so when someone's telling
me something that's making me mad,
I'll just slowly nod my head.
Like,
I understand this is the way things are.
I accept this and this is
calculating what my next move is
going to be. Uh and then you know,
you see whatever, you know,
guys will count to 10 you know,
you tell you a little kids that tell
you a little kids when they start losing
their temper,
you know what you need to count to 10
count to 10 count to a hundred counter
thousand,
whatever did you gotta do and
get control because like I said,
if you're losing control it's
not strength. It's a weakness.
Yeah.
I said this before where I read
this book called Mind Games.
Small little book.
Talked about anger management.
Like if people have anger
issues you realized it was
low or they said it was low
self as they say.
Yeah.
Anger issues stem from low self esteem
and that was really embarrassing.
You know,
I didn't have anger issues but I'm saying
if someone ever told me like oh you
have low self esteem or something like
that, that would be pretty embarrassing.
I always thought and so to
me I took that as an extreme,
being so sensitive to the,
even the expression low
self esteem. Now I was like,
oh I can never get angry
again. It says right there,
everyone gets angry, you know,
so that was always on my mind. Anytime
I started to feel mad, I was like,
okay,
I feel mad right now,
but I don't want to have low self
esteem so I better act. Right. You know,
kind of thing. And then after awhile
it just became habitual. Um, but the,
you know,
oh I see.
Like there's a difference between how you
feel and how you behave. Like you fit,
you have feelings, you know, but then
you know, you're mad.
Yeah. These mad feelings.
So what are you going to go and
straight up behave mad, you know? Yeah.
And a lot of people do it and a lot of
people we actually behave mad and justify
it because that's my true feelings. But
again, they're two different things, man.
Don't,
don't act toward your true
feelings in front of everybody.
Good. No, not good. Not Good.
Yeah. The, the, I dig it though.
Like, you know, cause you know that
feeling true feelings by the way.
The reason I'm saying that is if you
act on your true feelings all the time,
you won't get the long term
place where you want to be. Yeah.
True feelings do not lead you to your
true destination. Right? They don't want,
my gosh, so don't
actually, when you're fast,
keep your true feelings focused on the
true destination that you want to be at
and the true feelings that you have of
the anger and frustration and wanting to
yell at somebody and all that other
stupid stuff. Yeah. You know what?
You end up with a broken iPhone
cause you hooked it on the path.
That's what you went off with.
How's this
story time?
I'll make it quick.
So what am I crazy for a long time ago?
Oh my name is Chris.
So it's driving gets cut off
or something. You know, rotary,
just situation. True feelings,
right? True feelings. Oh that guy.
I want to beat him up. I want
to, I want to hurt him. Road
yells something or whatever.
Maybe other guy yelled at him first.
I don't know how, who started
what? But they pull over,
get into a fight that Chi in a way at the
time that feels like the fantasy right
there. Wish I could fight this guy.
I hope I the store I'm going to,
I hope he's right there so I can
fight them. I don't know. Whatever.
That's a fancy, that's
your feelings. So anyway,
Chris gets in a fight with this
guy on the side of the road,
grown adult by the way, fights
the guy, tears his peck tears in.
Chris tells his own peck. Yes. In the
fight. I Dunno if he won or lost whatever.
He's coming to work a little
bit. Doesn't matter. Yeah,
torn Pec is his six month injury
and the surgery yet, you know,
can you work with a torn Pec when most
of the time, probably not. You know,
and all because you know the guy cut
you off or wasn't going fast enough for,
it was going, you know, to
fat, whatever. You know,
it's one of those things and that's,
that's what your true feelings get you.
Was she in the moment, especially
when it's anger. It's weird.
We'll have to explore that at some point
because I know it doesn't make sense.
I'm not sitting here saying
everyone's suppress all your feelings.
All your real feeling. Yeah.
But the stupid feelings, do
you have suppressed those?
Let them let them manifest themselves
over time for a longterm result.
That's going to be what you actually
want in life. Usually the anger.
Yeah. Anger for sure. It's wonderful,
but anger, jealousy, uh, ego,
all those things.
Yeah.
Those are all things that if you
just act on them all the time,
you're not going to have a good time.
I'm life.
I'm here to tell you and every single
feeling when you're drunk next,
what are those? Those are not good.
Yeah. Don't act on those either.
Now she wished I led a
session based on the book,
extreme ownership to my team at work.
I'm not the leader, but everyone,
including our manager, was very
supportive and enjoyed the session.
The challenge from a team member was,
is there such thing as
taking too much ownership?
Why don't you start feeling guilty
about not succeeding completely?
This guilt would not be a good thing.
Thoughts on handling this?
Well, there's definitely a thing. You
can definitely take too much ownership,
but not for that reason. And I've
talked about this before, if you,
if you're taking to refine,
if you and I are on a team and I'm the
leader and we've got a mission and I take
so much ownership that I say, okay, echo,
this is how we're going to do everything.
You're going to listen to me, I own
this and I don't give you any ownership.
Now it's not your plan.
And so now you don't execute it the best
way and you don't buy into it and all
that stuff. So that is how you take too
much ownership. It takes away the no.
If you take too much
ownership as a leader,
you take away ownership from
your subordinates. And so
you've taken, and again,
it's that's overt ownership.
If I take over ownership now,
if I give you the mission and you go out
and execute it and you mess it up and I
say, okay, I coag didn't
give you enough guidance.
I didn't give you the support
and give you the training.
I'm going to own the mistakes.
I'm going to own the failure overtly.
But covertly. If I'm giving you
the mission, I'm going say, Hey,
you take it and run with it. So that's
where you need to be careful of that.
But guilt for failing
is not a valid cause.
Not to take ownership, right? Guess
what? When you fail something, yeah,
you're going to feel guilty, but
it's a different kind of you.
It's more of a disappointment
because things didn't go your way.
All right,
and I'll tell you when you feel guilty,
when you feel guilty to me is
if I know haven't done my best.
I know I cut corners. I know I
didn't invest the time. I know I,
you know, didn't give it
everything I could as a leader.
That's when I feel guilty.
If I give it everything and I've done
everything I can and I look back and of
course Hines, there's going to be
things that you didn't predict, right?
Hindsight's 2020 we all know that there's
going to be things where you look back
and you say, I wish I would've made a
different decision. But you have to.
You have to say, okay, so what are you
gonna do in the future? Be Indecisive now.
Are you not going to make decisions?
Even at that moment when I made the
decision which, which was wrong,
now that we can see hindsight,
well, what were you going to do?
You're going to wait and sit around
and do nothing and now we get attacked.
We get maneuvered on, we
get the competitor moves or
the enemy moves on as well.
So you might feel disappointed
that you made the wrong decision.
You might feel that type of guilt.
But w w the real guilt for me is if I,
I didn't give everything
I could to the situation.
So that's what causes guilt to me.
Now the failure,
okay,
an actual failure.
It shouldn't cause that level of guilt.
It should cause you to dig deep and
figure out what happened and want to
reattach it.
That's what it should do.
It should cause you to want to
figure out where you failed,
where your team failed, and what you can
do to ensure that never happens again.
If you want to call that guilt,
you can call it guilt,
but that is not a reason not
to take ownership. You know,
I might call it disappointment.
It's a, what I'll call it,
I'll call it motivation,
you know, and I, you know, I don't
throw that word around easily,
but if I fail at something,
I'm going to be motivated to make sure I,
I get it back on back in line and
get that thing squared away. So,
okay.
Take ownership. If you
know, take ownership,
get things done right.
And if you fail,
don't feel guilty, don't
get guilty, get aggressive,
find the problems and get them solved.
That's it. Re Attack Yemen. Makes Sense.
Yeah. So the guilt is what kind of like,
Dang, it's all my fault. Like knowing,
you know, taking ownership for sure,
but it's like, Dang, it's all my fault.
This failure. Look at everyone's, I know
a guy lost his commissioner on it. Right,
right. Dang. That kind of guilt
thing. Yeah. And you know,
I say this with businesses there.
Do you know, like you just said,
you make someone lose their commission
because you couldn't get the deal done
fast enough. You couldn't give the
guy the support that they needed.
Now they lose commission.
You can sure you can feel guilty
about that. Is that a reason not to
take ownership of it? Absolutely not.
It's a reason to take more ownership
and be like, okay buddy, echo,
I know you lost commission on that.
Here's what I think. I let you down.
Here's what we need to communicate better.
Here's what I need to prepare and be
ready to support you next time so this
doesn't happen again.
Are you with me? Right.
As opposed to saying not taking ownership
and saying, well, you know, Echo,
that was kind of, you know, those
deals don't always work out.
Maybe you should prepare better. Does
that make me feel good as a leader? Mouth.
It makes me feel like an idiot.
It's kind of like the swamps of sadness.
So the swamps upset,
sadness to me in when you get,
don't want to visit.
Those are some of the never ending
story when it's basically you go through
these swaps and it's super
hard. No, but it makes sense.
It's a metaphor for life. Lisa
was a movie. It's a movie.
It's a classic neverending
story. Yeah, the never ending
story. Anyway, the swamps,
the set, and it's, they're hard to walk
through them. It's like, it's hard.
It's a swamp. Quicksand everywhere,
quick swamp, whatever. You know,
they're not actually saying,
but so you sync and the more you sink,
the Saturday you get the set you get,
the more you sink. So you gotta like,
you know how you say,
oh,
like if someone's feeling guilty
in this case or if you get sad,
a lot of times you get sad and you're
like, oh, I'm such a sad downward spiral.
That downward spirals. Exactly.
So you got to fight this thing.
You got to fight this on to the
sadness and get aggressive and work.
It's not easy. Totally not easy.
That's what the why it's this one.
How do they cover the fact that if
you're in the swamp and you're sinking,
if you panic, you'll
also sync more. Oh yeah.
They didn't getting aggressive cause
getting aggressive might just be like
thrashing around and now you're running
out of breath as you're sinking. Yeah,
they'd cover that now that they don't
cover that, miss that on the metaphor.
They now need to rethink
the swan cassettes. No,
no. Well I don't think that
that was real in the water.
You know when you're in the
water. Yeah. If you get panicky,
your breath is going faster. Your oxygen's
going quicker, you're going to die.
You have to relax.
You have to learn to relax.
You got to have an ax and just
switch into problem solving mode.
Really
don't let this one,
but it is true that you can go in
the downward spiral and you know,
we see that in people's lives,
right. People's lives, they, they,
they mess, they lose their
job. And instead of going,
cool opportunity and somebody just hit
me up on social media the other day,
it's like, lost my job. Good. I got an
opportunity to go out, find another job.
I'm going to step up. Like
that's what you do. Yeah. Yeah.
And as opposed to boss my job,
oh no, what am I gonna do?
And now you start going down the downward
spiral because now you can't pay your
rent. Next thing you know, you're
losing your, your apartment and now you,
now you can't pay your car payment
either and now you're losing your car.
So what do we do? How does that
help? Doesn't help out. Don't panic.
Get aggressive.
Figure out what you're going to do next.
Take advantage of this situation. No,
Dang. That's good. Next
question. Next question.
Can you talk about the experience
of rolling with Hixon? Oh,
how impressed were you? Uh, I answered
this on Twitter. Someone said,
how impressed were you?
I responded, all caps.
Impressed.
So Jujitsu,
I, I was, this is backing, this is,
well, it's back in the dairy,
so it's back in the day.
And I was at team one at the time and,
and so I think we're talking 95 96 maybe,
maybe even.
Yeah.
95 96 maybe 97 I think
it was 97 and I was,
yeah,
it was 97 because I was working in
the training department and I was into
Jujitsu.
What else?
I was a blue belch and I wanted
to go and train with Hixon. Right,
because if you don't know anything
about Hixon for those people that aren't
Jujitsu players, Hixon is the, the,
he is considered to be the best ever
at Jujitsu and be above and beyond just
being the best ever.
Hixon Gracie being considered
the best ever at the sport.
He has a high level of mystique about him.
And you know, there's a bunch
of reasons for that mystique.
And there's a great story
and you know where I don't,
you know the story when the, the guy
from Japan challenged him. Yes. Yeah.
So guy from Japan, he beat one guy
in Japan and his teammates said,
I will fight you at any time.
The guy came to Hickson's academy and
challenged him to a fight and Hixon wasn't
there at the time. They
called, texted and said, hey,
this guy from Japan's here to challenge
your honor, Hickson is like, oh,
I'll be there in 15 minutes.
So Hixon came down,
they wanted to record it and he said, no,
you can't you. He goes, I will record it.
I will own the video and,
and we will fight now.
And Hixon annihilated him.
And that's one of the mystique source.
And actually the guy came back a little
while later and brought him a show gun
helmet and a Samurai sword
or something like that.
There's some drama before that though,
I think the guy went back and was like,
Yay him. And like a bunch of people
beat me or a bunch of you owe me up.
And they reported it and then thumb high,
I forget the details,
but somehow he was persuaded
to tell the truth. Yeah,
well they had a video of it.
Hickson Hickson actually out
of it in that video exists.
It's still the guy told the truth
and then it was, it was cool.
And the other thing that's crazy.
Well,
the other thing that adds to the mystique
of Hixon is that everybody that rolls
with them every week, multiple
times, five times, six times,
seven time world champion, Jujitsu
person rolls with them and they say,
I was helpless.
Like guys that are winning dominating
the world championships or saying,
you know,
he,
I was helpless and he's above and beyond
anybody else that I've ever rolled with.
So in,
you know,
Hickson's now probably 50 something
and he does not like rolling with the,
the competitive black belts
anymore. Uh, but this is, you know,
five years, no, maybe 10 years ago he was,
he was doing that and he wouldn't compete,
but the guys would come to train
with him and he'd destroy him.
And there's some great stories online
that a bunch of really good black belts
have said. I mean, really good
black belts have said, you know,
I was rolling with Hickson
and he just annihilated me.
So this is for me. You
know, I was a blue belt,
but it was a pretty good blue belt, you
know? Sure. A day from back in the day.
And this is the beautiful thing, you
know, I was at, I was at seal team one.
And so there's something to military,
you can get no cost orders, meaning, Hey,
you don't have to take leave,
but we'll give you orders to go somewhere
and we're not going to pay for it
because you know,
we don't,
we're not going to waste government money
or spend government money on what you
want to do, but we'll let you go
do it. So I got no cost orders,
basically seal team one said, hey, you
can go up and train. And so I did that.
This is at the old Pecos street
academy broken and it was weird.
And the Pico Street Academy
was kind of a um, a, um,
it was like a dance studio or something
where they would lay down mats.
And I went up there, I think, I think I
ended up staying up there for nine days.
I stayed at some crappy
hotel around the corner. And
when I got there, Hixon wasn't teaching.
So I go there and I, you know, hey,
I want to train. And the guy
that was there lemole who's,
uh, you know who that is,
right? Yeah, it was a heroine hedos.
What's his last name? Oh, I don't, I just
don't have the slip. It's a little wall,
right. So lemme awesome Jujitsu guy,
awesome black belt. And then, you know,
Hicks and Gracie black belt. And so
he's teaching and he's, you know,
and I was coming from
Fabio Santos who's a,
another Hixon black belt and you know,
my,
my original instructor in Jujitsu where,
you know,
he made all kinds of incredible Jujitsu
guys. Fabio did, you know, you got it.
Just all kinds. Greg trained,
Dean Higgs, James Craig called.
I mean all kinds of really good
high level guys coming out of Fabio.
And then there's a whole,
there's like another generation of black
belts or came out of Fabio too who are
all awesome Guy Tino and just a
bunch of really good guy. Eric.
Um,
anyways,
limo was another Hixon black belt and
he was sort of the instructor at the
school. So we, I get up there
and I'm taking the classes.
He teaches two classes a day
or maybe three classes a day.
So I'm just taking three classes a
day while he's teaching, you know,
one's in the day and he
has one in the afternoon,
he has one at night and I'm taking all
the classes and I'm learning, you know,
his style. And at this time,
honestly the styles weren't.
If you go to a different
school now you can,
there's a little bit more variance in
styles between schools at this time, man,
it was all closer to the source,
right? So all the styles were,
so it was closer to now.
Now we're actually getting beyond that
because now with youtube and everything
and everyone competing
so much all the time,
there's a much quicker transfer of energy.
But five years ago, eight years ago,
when you went to a different school,
that was a much different style.
But at this time, 20 years
ago there was, there was,
you know, it all came from the same
source. So it was much more similar.
So what I'm going to these classes to
three times a day and there there's a 10,
15 people, you know, and they're good. You
know, we're all probably about the same.
You know, he, there might've been a
purple belt or two and Lamar was awesome.
Super Cool Guy, real casual guy. And
so that's what the classes were like,
super casual.
We'd lay out the mats on the wooden
floor and the dance studio and then we'd,
we'd train and shoot the breeze. Kind of
like a Jiu Jitsu class, just laid back,
little stretch, maybe learn a move or two,
had some roles, little bit more relaxed.
Fabio, Fabio Santos runs ease more old
school and more regimented. You know,
Fabio,
you're going to get in there,
you're gonna do your warm up and then
you're going to learn some moves and then
you're going to train. Um, lemme was
a little bit more laid back. Cool.
Chill teaching,
really good stuff.
So that's Monday and then Tuesday and
then Wednesday and then, and then limo.
I was, you know, in the
afternoon on or in the evening,
on Wednesday or I think it wasn't free.
What day?
What was like Wednesday or Thursday? I
think it was a Wednesday. He's like, hey,
Hickson's going to teach tomorrow
night. And I was like, oh, awesome. So,
so I come in Thursday night,
I is,
I'm pulling up in my 1990 whatever,
like Dodge Caravan,
pull up and minivan man.
And so there's a cars, more cars.
And I was like, Ooh. So now
I walk in in, it's, it's,
there's people everywhere, right?
It's crowded, it's crowded.
It went from like 10 or 12
people in a class. Now we,
there's like a hundred people.
I'm serious.
We had to lay out like all these
different mats and everyone is quiet.
No one's talking.
It was,
I was doing one day,
so Hickson's there and he's,
you know, like in a corner,
you know, just cool, chill.
And he looks at Limo and he,
you know,
gives him like a head nod in the multiple
like, okay, well we're warming up.
And I was like, okay. So
everyone gets in the line,
they start doing the old school that
you did to work, running in a circle,
silence.
Like no one's saying anything.
It's just silence it so you
could feel the presence of Hixon.
There's a hundred people now,
there's 10 times as many
people and everyone's quiet.
Everyone's serious.
And then, you know, he,
we get done with like a 20 minute up of
stretching and exercise she has getting
after it and then he gets done.
He gets us all in a circle and the
circle is huge. And then, you know,
Hixon like walks out into the middle of
the mat and then he sits in the center
and you can hear a pin drop. It was, that
was that. There was that awesome. And,
and then he taught class.
He taught class and I took notes.
Um, and maybe at some point we can go
through all those notes that I took,
but there's one of the most important
lessons that I learned about Jujitsu as a
whole.
I learned that during that time,
and I actually,
the way Hixon told it,
I've translated into my own way
of saying it, but believe me,
it's close. Like it,
what it was, what it is.
Is this, okay. And
you've probably heard me,
I teach this to this day is if,
if you're playing basketball
or you're playing soccer,
I think soccer is what
Hixon used as the example.
If we're playing soccer and I w I
want to or for playing football,
cause you played football. If
I faint to the left, right?
You as a defender you have
to react to me. You, you,
if you don't move to the left,
I'm just going to go left and
you're going to be lost. So,
so when I faked to the
left and now you move,
I can quickly adjust back because I'm
one step ahead of you. It was a fake,
it wasn't a full commitment.
So I can get by you because,
because when you put your,
when you move your weight,
your weight is a real thing and you
have to place it into the ground.
And when you put your
weight into the ground,
it takes a quarter of a second to pull
that weight back off the ground and put
it in the other direction.
So the difference be in Jujitsu.
The guy on the bottom when you fake me,
I don't have to put my weight
anywhere at my, my, my,
my weight does not have to follow you
if you're on the bus with a guy on the
bottom in Jujitsu his way, he doesn't.
If you, if you shuck and Jive my weight,
I don't have to play my weight.
That's what,
it's really hard to like faint one
way and then run the other way.
It doesn't really work. And
you can, you do it. Yeah.
But it doesn't work
consistently in Jujitsu.
And so that was this huge lesson
to me that I've always remembered.
And W and the other part of it is,
was the hip movement and,
and how to move your hips on the bottom.
And if you don't move your
hips on the bottom, you're,
you're going to get your guard past.
And if you don't control the
hips when you're passing,
then you won't be able to pass the guard.
So I have a real,
I had a real focus for a long time of
how to keep my hips mobile on the ground
so that people couldn't pass my guard.
And it's something that I
still concentrate on interests.
And when you're passing the guard,
if you,
and again this is another thing you
might hear me tell people like, oh,
you got control of my legs.
Cool,
you didn't control my hips
and you can control my legs,
you can put pin him on the ground,
I can still move my hips.
Eventually it'll be a little
bit more tricky but I can do it.
So those were those two points
that I learned from Hixson.
I, I really focused on them
for a long period of time.
And so that was awesome.
And then of course I
rolled with fixing cars.
I was friends with Fabio and Fabio told
them I was going to be there and so he,
you know,
he was a great guy and you know,
rolled with me and like I said,
I was a blue belt and I was
a good blue belt. Right.
Meaning what are,
when I rolled with,
when I rolled with brown
belts and black belts,
which there weren't a lot of at the time,
I did really good. You know what I mean?
We were all competitive at,
at Fabio school at that time,
you know us guys that were really
hardcore, cause dean at this time was,
he might've been a blue
belt or a purple belt,
but we were the Guys Hague's was
a purple belt at the time. So,
so we were the guys and you know when
guys would come from Brazil off the
competition circuit to come in and
train at Fabio's when they'd stop by,
you know,
those guys would have a brown belts,
black belts are going against
dean lister and Higgs.
I mean those guys were not
getting, it was, you know,
Dean and he eggs were awesome.
Dean was phenomenal.
He eggs was phenomenal and I was in
the mix with those guys, you know,
so we were good is what I'm saying. So
what did it feel like to roll with Hixon?
I thought about this and I thought
about a way to describe it.
And this is the way I am going to describe
it. It's going to be hard to imagine,
but try and imagine it. Okay. Hey,
if you ever felt very quick,
a large amount of very quickly
rolling water or flowing water. Yes.
So a river,
a giant hose,
a pipe with water like coming out of it.
And when you stick your hand,
like you can't barely resist it,
that much water.
So imagine that feeling of force,
but it's not going fast. It's
going slow. It just, it don't,
you can't stop it and wherever,
but just like water.
So it's like that much force. But just
like water, wherever you go to stop it,
it just goes around it. And it was
that, that was what, what it was like.
And I'm really,
really just phenomenal Jujitsu.
And I mean even at that time
and remembering back to it,
it was a nother level of Jujitsu for sure.
That was was awesome. And now, so
yeah, that's, that's wrong and fix.
And I still actually, I got some
mutual friends with Hickson and uh,
I see him occasionally.
And
you know, the, the, the
cool thing about Hixon is
he's got a personality
that
I would love to tell you that he's,
you know,
like a stereotypical peaceful warrior
master that seems content with where he's
ended up in life and with
his experiences in life.
But with Hixon,
I get the feeling that,
okay,
he's a guy that fighting is in his blood.
Right. And even though he's a mellow guy
and he has nothing to prove to anybody,
I think, and it, it kind of
feels like the way I feel.
He likes the taste of blood, you
know what I mean? And even though,
even though I'm kind of the same
way, like I feel like, you know,
I'm pretty mellow. I mean, I
don't, I don't have anything,
I'm not trying to prove anything to
anybody. I guess maybe I am in some ways,
but I'm pretty mellow.
But I still,
I like the taste of blood
and I love that feeling of
combat.
And that's kind of what you said.
That's what I sense from
Hickson and so, yeah. Awesome.
And maybe we'll have him on here sometime.
Hixon grace. He does have that mystique
though. That's it is crazy how that is,
you know, and it's because it's
real. Yeah. It because it's real.
You can go and like I said,
Google Hixon Gracie stories or
Hixon Gracie black belt stories.
There's stories where he would
line up 10 black belts and say,
I'm going to submit you all have
with an arm lock on your right arm.
And he would do it and he
would do it. And that's,
and so the, yeah, that build you
some mystique for sure. Yup. Yes.
I, one time I went, I was
going to film with him,
just like a quick video clip with me and
Halleck flew into crones academy Kron
Gracie Academy.
And so I get there and he's there already,
you know,
and he had, so guys were
leaving, they were done training,
guys were leaving and Hallux like,
Hey,
I'm going to be like 45
minutes to an hour late.
So it's just me and Nick's in there
and the whole like, everyone's gone.
So he's like, yeah, I was
like, oh yeah, no, I was there
to film. I would have been,
hey, you got your geezer? He
had his pants on. Oh, scared.
I submitted to the mystique.
But no, we're uh, you know,
we were waiting for a helicase. Oh Yeah,
how lucky me later, whatever. He was like,
yeah, yeah, I know. He, he told
me or whatever. So he's like,
he's kind of just there looking at me.
So we just sit down.
I got to talk to Hexion for like 15
minutes, just about whatever, you know.
And he's kind of looking at me like as
if to say like, so what, uh, you know,
who are you and what do we do? All
cool. But he was still Hicks and Gracie,
so my mind kept while we were talking,
my mind kept going into like jumping
outside of my brain and thinking I could
look what you're doing right
now you're sitting with Hixon.
You know how like after we roll
and we don't have anywhere to be,
we'll be just talking about stuff. He's
sitting there. Most people. That's how,
and I was doing that with Hixon Gracie,
that just me and him Bro. That's crazy.
Right? I mean, you know,
as a, as someone who knew,
I know who that is from the beginning,
even before I even started. You did sue.
I know who that is. Yeah. So yeah,
man. I was like, how I was funny too,
his bed that night,
back in the day he brought,
he brought his sons with him as well.
Hawkson was there and chrome was there.
Corn was a little kid, man, tiny kid.
And Fabio told him that I was in the seal
teams and stuff and that's, you know,
so he told me he had a
little conversation. That's
another funny thing. He said,
so when are we got done rolling?
And we were talking like yours are saying,
and he says to me, he
goes, you know, so hey,
they don't affect your role whenever he
goes. Yeah. He said, uh, you're, you're,
you're very comfortable in bad
positions. Right. Right off.
I'll take it, I'll take
it. It's, I do this too.
Sometimes when people used to ask me,
hey, what was it like rolling with x?
And I'd say, okay, let me get your
guard. And then I'd get in their garden.
They'd say,
okay now and then I'd say,
okay now just relax and let me pass
and then I would just pass their garden
mountain. I said that's what
it feels like. That excellent,
very comfortable in bed.
That's kind of like after you
like box a guy and you say, hey,
you can take punches. Right. Good.
Basically your face is tough
and that's another fear.
I mean I kind of held onto that like
I always like to be comfortable in bad
positions.
Dean,
it's really good because when I turned
with dean all the time and so you know,
there's no one that that I roll with
on a regular basis at a roll with some
really good guys.
But when Dean is mounted on you or
when Dean is on side control on you,
it is insufferable,
bad position.
And especially because like I'll roll
with I role with other really high level
guys that aren't from our school.
And when I roll with them,
if they get a position like that,
they don't know exactly my every
little escape. Dean knows exactly.
He knows, he knows all 14 of
my escapes. He knows them all.
So you're more trapped on more trout.
And it's the same with him.
When I get to position I know
what he's going to do. I know.
And so he and I joke
about it, you know, eat,
neither one of us want the other
person to be, especially across side,
you know, and we don't want that. So
I guess that's an accident. Acid in
boxing too, if you can take punches.
Oh for sure. He's comfortable
in bad positions in Jujitsu.
Is is Kinda like back when
you were talking about the,
when you're in water and things
are going bad, dark panic.
If you're comfortable in bad positions,
like you have the ability to yeah,
to not panic. And that helps so
much because when you panic you gas,
Hey, do you make stupid
mistakes and Jujitsu, you
make stupid mistakes, so yeah,
man, I'm just going to push this leg out
of here. Oh, now he's grabbing my arm.
Yeah. Yeah. He wanted you to do
that. That's good compliment.
Next question.
In podcasts,
50 for the Armed Forces officer, remember
that book? Their Armed Forces officer?
Yeah. One of my feet. 1950 edition. Yeah.
Can you expound on the
difference between these two?
These two seemingly contradictory
quotes from the manual,
affirm hold at the beginning pays 10
fold dividend of the timid approach
followed by a show of firmness later on
from general Malone story of a World War
One
compared with and General Malone's.
If you remember the story was there's
mad messed up unit and he went in there.
It was like, all right, get squared
away. Get these boards in place,
get out of the mud. What you need
to get your uniforms together.
Just tighten them up out of the gate
like firmness right from this way out of
the gate and then compare it
two. Okay. Here's the quote.
It's a mistake for an officer on taking
a new post to order sweeping changes
affecting the other man in the belief
that this will give him a reputation for
action and firmness.
The studying of situations is the
overture of the steadying of it,
and that's from general
in general. We're May, if you
remember that one, he said, hey,
none of you guys would be
in these positions unless
you were doing things right.
So I assume that you're doing a good job
and we're going to continue what you're
doing.
That's what he said when he took over.
So what's going on here is you've got
two completely different situations and
the two situations are,
one is a guy taking over first situation,
a known bad situation.
The troops are lacking discipline.
They're not executing the mission.
If you remember for that story,
they weren't even doing basic
military bearing. They didn't,
they weren't saluting the officers.
They just hadn't thrown
everything out the window.
That's a situation where you got to come
in, you got to get from out of the gate.
That's what you gotta do.
Now they got to know that.
They got to know that things are gonna
Change. They got to know it's real.
They got to know there's a new plan and
I got to know what that new plan is and
then they got to know that there's new
standards and they got to know what the
new standards are. Boom. And it's the same
thing. You know, Hackworth. He did that.
He came in with some, you know, if
you remember when he took over the,
the hardcore battalion,
what became the hardcore battalion,
the first thing he did was like all those
radios and guitars and all this crap
that you have sitting around base.
Put it all in the middle of the base
tomorrow and we're getting rid of it all.
That was a big change.
Now Hackworth.
Then he, then he started implementing
two changes a day. If you remember,
hey gotta get everyone can
carry your weapon at all times.
That's the neck change. Okay,
get your helmet. Now we've
got to get helmet covers.
When he just made one,
one or two small changes a day after he
made some big sweeping changes out of
the gate because it was a
jacked up battalion and now,
now the differences,
if you're going into a situation where
everything's going fine or okay or at a
bare minimum it's like normal,
well then you don't need to step in there
and show that you're have a manned by
making these sweeping changes. You
don't need to do that. It comes across,
it comes across like the people that you
just took charge of have no idea what
they're doing and get you don't, you
don't respect what they did, what they,
what their methodology.
You don't respect their,
their performance because you're coming
in and saying, oh, echo, by the way,
the way you report cord, the podcast,
you need to get rid of those microphones.
You need to edit it tighter your basis to,
you know,
what would you be thinking
if I came in and said that?
Well,
you know
me a little bit different, but you know,
I understand your pain point being.
If somebody comes in and
starts criticizing you
right when you do it. Okay.
When you're doing a good job, we
know you're doing a good job. Yeah,
I think you're doing a good job.
There's something that I get on you about
that base. Occasionally that's your,
that's really on you. You know
you're blocking your base. But yeah,
so that's the thing. If that's the
decision you gotta make, and guess what?
It's not black and white.
You don't go into some units.
It's not like you're going to get a choice
between a unit that's doing horrible
and a unit that's doing great.
You're going to get every thing in
between and therefore you have to modulate
your leadership to reflect.
If it's a,
if it's a group that might have a tendency
of being a little bit jacked up and
they're getting close, guess
what? Gotta gotta gotta beat.
Maybe not sweeping changes, but you might
need to make a little statement, right?
If it's a group that's performing
awesome, fantastic top, top team,
top, whatever, you might need
to come and say, hey guys,
I see that you're doing great.
I'm here to just keep you
guys doing what you're doing.
Let me know what you need to support.
Boom.
And it could be anywhere
in between that spectrum.
That's why leadership is challenging,
cause you gotta be able to got to have
nuance. You gotta be able to modulate.
Yeah. You gotta figure out where that
is and you've got to test it out to,
once you give that sweeping order,
you've got to see what kind of reaction.
Gotcha.
You know, you've got to see two
people just instantly rebel. Okay.
Then let's talk this. Let's get
some feedback. What's going on?
Clearly we have a disrespect scenario
going on. When you get to bottom of this,
let me get some key leaders in here.
Let me talk to them, get some feedback,
which you should do that before you
make any sweeping changes anyway.
He got to at least talk to the key
leadership. Get them in the game.
Get them on board. Yeah. That's why
leadership is awesome. That's why I beat,
that's why this stuff is so
fun because it's challenging.
It's different every single
time it feels like, um,
kinda like what we were talking about
earlier where if you start to understand
the formula,
all the different details that come out
and you can kind of apply the formula in
one way and even then still
dynamic, but, but you can,
you can just get a better grass.
Just like Jujitsu.
If you understand the concept that
you have to be able to move your hips,
there's a bunch of different ways
you can get your hips moving, right?
If you understand the concept that you
need to mobilize the hips to pass the
guard,
if you understand that concept,
there's all kinds of
different ways you can do it.
If you understand the concept of totally
jacked up team is going to need a
sweeping change to get their attention
and get them to understand that things
are gonna change and what they
were doing was unacceptable.
If you understand that concept,
that that's what it's going to take,
you can apply it all the way through those
gradiations all the way down to, hey,
this team is doing great and
I don't need to change much.
I just need to give them the support
that they need. Conceptual instruction,
very important.
That's what Jocko,
I recently listened to the strategic
con podcast while on my way to coach
Lacrosse and I was impressed how many
of the points made between both Maurice
and your experience as an operator
translated into the field.
Another point of the cast that stuck
out and now I reflect on as learning
experience and coachable moment for
myself was the saying of good work.
When we recently battled through uh, uh,
the first half we game lacrosse game,
it was a grudge match in
this one he's talking,
I edited a little bit out of this
because he had a really long email and we
believe in brevity around here.
So he's actually now talking about a
soccer match grudge match, set their plan.
Okay. So boom, they had a hard first
half. It was a grudge match. Uh,
I'm very evenly played until,
until the half when I told the boys they
were doing good work out there and that
we were matching their intensity
and putting pressure on them.
Then the first 30 seconds of the second
half we were scored on due to lack of
intensity and follow through. I suspect
it may have been from my good job,
quote unquote good work. Keep it up
talk we had in the inn at the halftime.
My question to you is how
does one reinforce the fact
they were hitting hard up
there?
Give them some words of encouragement
and send them back out without taking a
hit in intensity as the coach of freshmen
high school boys who are basically
wild dogs and need direction plus support,
what could I have done different to keep
the intensity up in the second half and
even after getting scored on?
So this is,
this is pretty simple and I've
actually talked about this before. Um,
I've talked about it with regards to MMA
and I've talked about it with regards
to my seal platoon,
my seal task unit.
And that is that you have to be very
careful with praise. Oh yeah, yeah.
Because in the example that I give in
the corner of MMA fights is if you tell
the guy, hey, good job. You know
you're, well, you won that last round.
Keep just keep doing what you're
doing. He's going to back off. Yeah,
he's going to back off. And guess
what the other corners telling him,
you lost that round. You need to step
it up. You need to get aggressive.
And that's what they're going to do.
They're going to get out
there because I'll tell you,
most people in an MMA fight,
MMA fight is a, it's like
wrestling. It's a very intense
cardio activity. You're good.
Everybody's going to be tired, beat
just about everybody. I mean obviously.
So when you get two guys will,
let me, let me rephrase that.
When you get two guys that are evenly
matched and are going at it hard,
they're both going to be tired and so
they're going to want a little bit of
arrest.
So if you give them that opportunity to
back off the throttle just a little bit,
subconsciously they're going to do it
because they think they're doing good.
They think that one that last round, so
you can see that all the time. You see,
I mean, it happened, it happened with
Rhonda. You know, they're saying, hey,
good job, good job. You're looking
good. And she's getting crushed.
I mean, that's kind of a
bad example. But anyways,
you gotta be careful that in,
in, I've told this story before,
but when my tasking was going
through training and uh,
we will doing CQC, so close
quarters, combat drills,
we're going in to kill house
over and over and you know,
we broke for lunch or something.
We come back from lunch and the guy
that is the Kadri, they're like, hey,
you guys are kicking ass. This is great.
Keep it up. You guys are two best task.
You know, we've seen out of
here. You guys are crushing it.
And literally the next run guys go in
the house, they screw everything up,
they miss targets, just a disaster.
And I talked to the contrary. I'm like,
don't ever tell my guys again that they're
the best guys in the world. Don't ask,
don't tell them that you
can tell him good job,
but don't be telling them they're
the best people in the world.
Just doesn't work. And so that's
kind of what happened. You know here.
Now the thing is,
this doesn't mean that you can never
give anybody credit or never give anyone
praise because you absolutely have
to do that. But what you have to do,
you have to proactively counteract the
mental lapse in intensity that's about to
take place because you just compliment
them. So how do you do that?
So let's say you're on the
lacrosse field or the soccer field,
you bring the boys in. You
say, look guys, good half good.
First half of you took it to them.
You showed them that we can hang with
them. You played him even. That's fine.
Here's a problem.
Even isn't good enough.
We need to get out there and play harder.
We need to step it up. I actually
want you guys to play like murderers.
That's what I want you to do.
I want you to win every loose ball.
I want you to make every tackle.
I want you to get your head on
every ball that's in the air.
You stick to them on defense. I don't
even want them to be able to breathe.
I want you to work them into the ground.
I want pressure, pressure, upfront,
pressure in the midfield and pressure
on d you make them fight for every inch,
every ball,
and every breath.
I want you to go out there
and take their souls.
So you got to counter that. You know,
you got to counter the good job thing.
So in MMA it's the same thing.
You know, hey, good round.
Who was a close but a good round. But
listen, you can't let up right now.
You need to step it up. He knows he
has to step it up. I'm telling you,
he knows he's got to step it up.
And if you come out week,
he's going to get the upper hand
right away. You need to put him away.
You need to go out there and crush him,
crush his soul,
turn it on and put this guy away.
I want you to kill him.
So that's what you need to do with that.
Now for tactical training.
Same thing. Cause you know,
I know this police officer's and Swat
teams and t and guys that are in the
military,
you're doing tactical training all the
time and you're going to see that as the
team comes together, they're going
to start to do good. But like I said,
if you give them too much,
they're going to slack, right?
So you know when you're running your
tactical training, you for your guys,
you say, look, hey guys, I see
some good progress out there.
We're making some good runs.
But let me tell you it's not good
enough for it right now. Okay,
this is the deal. The enemy can rely on
luck. We can't, we rely on our training.
We trained to be prepared for
anything that the enemy throws at us.
So we're going to work as hard as
we can and be as perfect as we can.
So we are ready for the
worst case scenario.
So get jacked up for
another run right now.
And I want you to go in there like a band
of bloodthirsty viking shock troops on
our damn berserker rage and crush this.
So you want to bring that
kind of counts right?
And then in combat again,
and I just was talking to some guys
yesterday and it's the same thing where
complacency is the worst thing that can
happen with your team when you're in a
combat scenario. So what were your
combat? You know, it's look, hey guys,
we're running some good operations,
right?
We got the upper hand and that's good,
but it's not good enough.
We cannot be complacent and we can't
take our foot off the enemy's throat.
We are going to be relentless.
We are not going to give
him the chance to regroup.
He will not get the chance to recover.
There will be no downtime for the enemy.
And I'll tell you what,
I don't even want the enemy to
have a chance to bury their dead.
We are not going to stop until there is
nothing left to pursue and no one left
to bury. So sharpen up your
knives, load up your magazines,
because we got work to do.
So again,
we got to counter,
you know,
the compliments and balance.
Essentially what I'm doing in
each one of those situations,
I'm balancing the positive affirmations
of what is happening with some new goals
and new objectives that will
ensure that there will be no slack.
Yeah,
so the guy said
they were ninth graders. Freshman.
Yeah, freshman wild dogs. Yup.
Yeah.
Next question.
How do you detach without
seeming completely cold?
Okay,
important question.
No, I'm saying this all time.
You know, you got to detach.
I also say all the time,
if you detach from all your emotions,
that means your robot and people don't
fall robots. I say it all the time.
So when you do detach,
you can't,
you can't completely step away.
But if you do,
you have to.
You have to act.
You have to do a little
acting. Now, first of all,
we already talked about this, right? We
already talked about these red flags, that
debt
show that you're going
to lose your temper,
that you're going to get emotional
about something. You know,
you're clenched fist and you're raised
voice and your heavy breathing and your
flared nostrils and all that stuff,
right? So you know what those things mean.
Those things mean those things are your,
your signal that mean detach. Okay,
so you got to work on that.
Now here's the dichotomy of it is once
you are there and once you have detached,
you actually have to now go back
and do
one or some of those things
that you are trying not to do.
You have to go and you have
to do them a little bit
in a nice little controlled manner, right?
Maybe raise your voice a little bit.
Hm.
Maybe you just kind of clench your jaw
on and you remember I said to you like,
like nodding your head in a positive way.
And that's when you,
if you're coming to me with an issue
and I nod my head to the affirmative,
you know, up and down saying,
yes, I understand. Yes,
I understand that's a soothing thing to
your team, right? They see that you're,
you're okay with it.
The opposite of that is when you
shake your head in the negative.
Like if you're telling me some
problem and I'm shaking my head,
it's like Amigo and Tim, I can't believe
this is going on. Right. So yeah.
So maybe that's another thing that you,
you,
you clench your jaw and you shake your
head. Did you show the person like, look,
I know we're in a bad way.
I get it.
I'm not sitting back here like it's no
big deal. I know it's gonna be a tough,
I know we just lost a sale
or I know we just, you know,
I'm going to have to plan another
mission that we just got back.
I understand that it's
hard. You care. I care.
You know I'm with you.
You want to give that,
maybe you let out that little sigh of
frustration, you know, like a little,
like something like that, right?
Just going to do that little thing.
You just do that just so showing that
you do got some emotions and you are
invested in all that stuff.
And,
and then once,
once you see that you've
achieved your goal here,
that you can see that,
that they see that you have some
emotions on the situation, then you,
you quickly get yourself
to recover from that.
You get yourself composed and
you've shown them and they,
and they've seen that it's almost like
a little to see like a little weakness
and they go, okay, you don't, Tacos
are human related. Yeah, I can relate,
but he's mad. But you know what?
I actually want him to calm down.
I actually am glad he's so good.
Yardi, I'm using two. What?
I'm glad he's calming
down. That's good. Okay,
so the new recover and you go back
to your calm, cool. Collected self,
right. That's what we're going
to do now. Like I said, this is,
do we call this acting?
I guess maybe we could call it acne,
but at the same time acting means
you're trying to pretend to be somebody.
You're not trying to pretend to
be anybody else. You're being you.
That's all you're doing. You're being
you. You're just acting like yourself.
Just showing a little bit
more of the emotion. And
then you would be if you were
just completely detached.
So it's not like you're trying
to act like some, you know,
junior. Yeah. You're not trying to, to,
to play a role of someone
else or just being you. So,
and you already know what you
do because you've learned how,
what the signals are.
So when you know that you raise your
voice and that means you're okay,
then you just raise your voice a
little bit. If you know that you,
you just give a little sites.
It's those careful things.
And so, yeah, I guess
it is acting in a way,
but it's not full on anybody
can do it, I think. Yeah.
Yeah, you did. I think that's
great. This is my opinion.
You do it with your kids, you
know? Oh, I mean, I'm like,
you got to pretend to act gay. You know,
you're mad or, or whatever. Any good.
Even happy,
even pretend to act happy.
I needed excellent. Okay. We'll say
excited. Hey, I got something for you.
It's a drawing of a happy face.
Same as she did yesterday. You know?
And it's like, I'm not the honest truth
is I'm excited about other things.
We'll just say that bro.
I'm all those loved all that love
you got for crying about that letter.
You're going to, you're going to
know it's all going backwards now.
People are going to hate
you. Now rob talking about
exciting your daughter Josie,
a beautiful picture and you don't
care about it. It was cold blooded.
What I'm going to give her
is a lot of excitement.
I'm going to match her excitement.
Maybe even go one level higher.
That's what I'm going to give her.
So what am
I'm excited about? A lot of other things
a little bit though, right? It's the same.
Same thing. Uh, that was messed
up by the way. Same thing. Yeah,
it's,
is it a form of manipulation?
It might be a little bit of a
form of manipulation, but again,
if you're doing it to the individual
and you're doing it to help the team,
then isn't manipulation or is
it leadership? I say, of course,
if leadership you're not
manip manipulation is,
I'm trying to fool you so you do things
that I want you to do that we're not
doing that.
It's not what we're running here.
All right, next question. Next question.
Please discuss how disciplined in one
area doesn't make up for slack in other
areas. For example, the fit is
guru who has no savings. Mm.
Yeah.
You know,
this is something that we all have to
work out for watch out for is the fact
that we, we focus on our strengths,
right? That's what we do.
That's what people do. So you get
a person that's smart, you know,
really intellectual person and they let
themselves go physically, right? Right.
You know, or you get a person
that's a physical stud,
but then they're not going to
challenge their brain power.
Or like the question that was,
you know,
the example here that was posed,
someone that's a fitness guru or a party,
Google who,
I'm throwing that one out there because
some people really go to that or they,
you know,
they're an entrepreneur.
I'm an entrepreneur and so
they're driving a new Mercedes,
but it's leased and
they're behind on payments.
So strategically yet.
Yeah. Yeah. That, um,
so you,
you know,
I mean you take another example is what
about the business person that doesn't
have time for their family, right?
Yeah. And so that's not good.
So I think the focus here is your,
we try and we all have to be,
try to be well rounded and not focus so
much on one area that you're going to
let some of that area go. That's
target fixation is what that is, right?
Is you walk into a room and you get
fixated on one target, one bad guy,
you think there's one bad guy.
So you focus all your energy
and then you're getting fined.
That's target fixation.
You can't let that happen.
You can't let it happen on
the battlefield. You can't
let it happen and the life.
So look out for that when you
do this. Um, and I'll tell you,
this is actually a reality
of the situation. Um,
I try and maintain this balance,
but I've been actually
working a lot lately.
And what,
and this is a clear indicator to me that
I've overbooked myself is last week we
had this eye,
we had to skip a day of Jujitsu to record.
I mean we don't do that right? When did
we record rear corner after Jujitsu.
But I knew I had so much
stuff going on that I said,
hey we gotta we gotta record at this time
because I got to get this other stuff
done because I'm traveling and this and
that. And so we had to skip those huge,
it's cut. So that is a red
flag to me that says I need to,
I need to tighten up, I
need to get my, you know,
get my schedule back in
check so that I can do the,
that I need to do. Of course.
What do I say about the situation?
It's fine. You know what? Can't train
Jiu Jitsu that day cause I'm trying,
I got some travel coming up.
Good.
I'm going to heal up my shoulder a little
bit more. I'm going to, as you know,
I'm going to, it's, it's good, it's fine,
but it is an indicator of when things
start going in the wrong direction.
Maybe I'm getting target
fixated on you know,
too much work at a certain time,
which to me again,
I will run this thing in the red as you
say. I like, I like running in the red,
right?
I'm in the red and I got no problem.
Like we will go hard in the numbers
of hours I've been where I will work.
We'll have actually no impact on how
much I'm going to tell them to spend with
my family and do Jujitsu and all
that stuff cause I'll just do it all.
But there is a capacity
that you reach where you go,
okay now one of these things
that has just started to slide,
now I need to make sure that
my levels get re re levels,
I guess you might say equalized
is what I should have said. Uh,
so back to the subject. Don't
be a one trick pony, you know,
be a jack of all trades and then
master a few of those traits.
And so you can emphasize fitness guru,
you can emphasize intellectual power,
you can emphasize Jujitsu,
but don't put 100% of your effort into
one area because eventually it will take
you, you won't have anything else. And by
the way, if you put all your, you know,
if you put all your, all your eggs
in the basket of intellectual power,
now you're unhealthy and you die,
right? That, that doesn't, you know,
I don't care how smart you are, you
can't do two plus two when you're dead.
So don't put all your
focus 100% into one area.
Don't become unbalanced in
your disciplines is spread
it around and hold the
line.
Yeah man.
Good. Yeah. Again, it kind of feels like,
like he can be understood that,
um,
say I'm real good at, I
dunno, fitness [inaudible]
and it's easy to justify yourself. You
know, like your, your, let's say, okay,
I'm real good at fitness, fitness
guru. And I go around and then I see,
I don't know,
I go to the store or go to some party
and I see this other guy who's like
socially,
he's just hundred percent everyone likes,
he's such a nice careers. Madec I
makes a lot of money in all this stuff,
but he's not in that good a shape for,
I don't know. He smokes and whatever,
you know, it's ease. I
think a lot of people,
whoa,
it feels like it's easy to justify wolf
that guys in bad shape. So who cares?
I really didn't want any of that. I
wouldn't want all the money. You know,
all this stuff.
It seems like you had to justify and
he north the other guy saying, yeah,
you might be in good shape. Guessing
what? They're nice Toyota Corolla.
You're driving these all
negative on him. Yeah. Yeah.
So both those guys should, it should,
instead of saying, Hey, you know what?
They should do, walk up
and be like, hey man,
you know what I noticed were
pretty successful financially.
I would like to get in the
game with you a little bit and,
and learn from you about that. And
the other guy should say to him, well,
you know what? It looks like you're
in pretty good fitness levels.
I would like to get in the game with that.
Let's work together and improve ourselves
and go out and kick ass and dominate.
Are you in? I'm in. Let's do this instead.
What does a normal person do? They do
exactly what you said. Justify, criticize,
cut people down instead
of building them up. Yeah.
And what you have to be careful of, if I
was to go to you and say, hey, you know,
echo, I got a lot of money. I can tell
you don't have a lot. I'll help you out.
That's, that can be offensive to
some people because you think,
do you think you are? Yeah. You
can sit back and read your hell.
I'm going to worry about money.
I think I'm worried about money.
When I got abs like,
Yo,
so what we have to do is instead of,
if I came to you and said, echo dude,
I want abs like you got,
can you help me get in the game?
And then we formed a little
relationship and now I say to you, man,
so what do you got? What's your, what's
your main income stream dude? You know,
what are you doing? And you say, well,
you know, I've got these two clients.
If you've got a website, no, not
really. Why don't you have a website?
Do you got any social media
to advertise on? You know,
when we go though that road and we
build up, we take care of each other.
So we don't want to do as people
kind of like you ever
seen the guys who go,
they see like a football player
or something. It'd be like,
I can kick his ass though.
You know,
you know that Kenga got who
can always like some success.
He kick his ass though.
Yeah.
Well I've told the story
in the seal teams, it's uh,
no one, no one is good. If, if a guy,
like we have guys in the seal
teams that are literally, you know,
world class athletes in whatever world,
class triathlete,
world class, sailor worldclass, whatever.
And so, oh you, oh, you're, you're
world class triathlete. Oh yeah.
That guy's really good triathlete.
That's cool. He's a really bad shot.
Someone who's going to chime in and
cut them down and just the way it goes.
No slack, no slack. Slack. Right.
We'll go one more I think so, uh, Jocko,
would you confront an individual team
member when reported by other team members
that they're talking smack about you?
Or would you just ignore
the old classic here?
What do you do about the,
about the negative guy
that's trying to bring you
and sure you can,
you can confront them right?
And you can, by doing that,
join in there in their little game
in,
in doing that,
you give them the satisfaction.
They now know that they,
they got into your head
and then you're turning your
workplace into, you know,
your basic grade school gossip,
Paul.
So we don't like that.
But now there are times,
unfortunately that's you. You have
to address things and when you do it,
you do it professionally and you do it.
Your goal is to disarm them because
remember that this negative person inside,
they
probably want the confrontation.
That's what they want. And so you
know, you say something like, Hey,
I heard you had some critique points
for me about how I'm doing my job.
You know, if if I'd love to get your
feedback so I can tighten up my game.
She just disarm him a little
bit and something like that.
We'll likely diffuse the scenario
a little bit and you know,
hopefully the people under the,
the,
the person will understand that there
are other people that are telling you
what's going on. It'll kind of put them
in check and stifle the situation. But
deep preferred methodology
for this situation for me
is quite simple and that is
ignore an outperform them.
You see,
while you're over there watching
me and talking about me,
I'm working, I'm working hard, I'm
taking things to the next level.
You Keep Gossiping and out,
keep working.
You keep talking smack
and I'll keep working.
You keep focusing on everything.
And everyone else and I'll keep working.
And when you finally look around
at where you are and where I'm at,
you'll realize that you have
nothing left to talk smack about.
Okay.
Eight you will lose an eye will whip.
And this key or applies to when people
are playing office politics or forming
their little cliques or
working their personal agendas.
And again, I know sometimes
you have to play those games.
Yeah.
But
let your first course of action lift the
fundamental core of your reaction be to
outwork and out perform
every last one of them.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles.
Yes.
Speaking of work,
do work.
Why don't you just go ahead and put
in some work right now and let him,
everybody know how they can support
this podcast if they want to.
They want to actually,
you know what I'm talking about?
I'm talking about the work I did today.
Hm.
Make [inaudible] 15 all
that. Anyway, um, anyway,
we'll talk about on it. You
want to support this podcast,
support yourself on it.
What's the of the Krill oil? It's real.
It's real. And I thought about this,
like I'm kind of lifting kind
of hard and like I do, um,
like squats right to the very like
different kinds and different weights.
And do you do overhead squats?
Sometimes you do at overhead squat?
Not a lot. I would call it a
lot, but just one that that is
like one that you can do it all,
like front squats or something like that.
But I go all the way down all the way
down the caters to squat. Yeah. Well some,
sometimes you know,
people don't have the flexibility in
their feet or their ankles or whatever or
you know, you're lifting like 500 pounds
or something going all the way anyway.
My point is it can be hard on your knees.
It can't straight up those, those
are the facts. It can be anyway.
And I'm kind of going
and cut hard nowadays,
like pretty much everyday
lift and Jujitsu, you know,
like harder than I have in the past
for sure. And I don't have the, anyway,
the crude, the point is the Krill oil,
Krill oil is real. Well, I don't have any,
any pain. No pain, no pain, no pain.
Still going.
She's still like three a day.
Three in the morning and three at
night. Just three days. Three a day.
I do twice as much as you.
Well, you're bigger and older.
Do you mean bigger and bigger?
Factually older.
Oh yeah. Yeah, and I was thinking
zero before. Keep that in mind too,
but yeah, man, it's good.
Krill oil. That's the,
what's funny is when
you think supplements,
that's you think like somebody that's
going to make me stronger, you know,
if I take it versus don't take it. Well,
I guess cruel. It does make you stronger,
but it's like indirect
out more. Yeah. You know,
I've been taking krill oil for so long.
I don't even know what it's like
to not take krill oil anymore.
Things just one big
mystery.
No one big path to victory when you,
when to take the Krill oil on it.
Ecologically friendly harvesting of Krill.
Watched the video on a.com [inaudible]
dot com slash chocolate if you want 10%
off a pre workout,
which is total strength and performance,
he'll give you more strength
and more performance.
My anecdotal shroom tech proof,
by the way I, I got on, I had a bunch
of, like I said, I've been working a lot,
I've been traveling a lot.
When you're traveling,
you're getting on planes with a bunch
of people that you don't know and they
have all kinds of germs as do I.
And so people get sick and I can't be
sick and do my job because I've got to go
talk to people and meet people and it
gives speeches and all that stuff so I
can't be getting sick.
So I knew I had critical events coming up.
So guess what?
I did shroom tech immune.
Oh I did this room tech immune. Okay.
Powered through. You're not sick now. No,
I'm not sick now. Nope.
Training hard surf today.
So it'd basically and
worked out and got after it.
So Dang immune to the sickness.
So Dang,
there's another one in the rotation. Is
that what we're saying and, and yeah,
I cycled it.
Yeah.
I just cycled it because I
knew I didn't want to get sick.
And I suppose you could just say, hey,
have, when do you want to get sick? Right.
We never, yeah. Maybe it's something I
should take more often. Yeah. It's, well,
and it's one of the things kind of like,
um,
like a backend computer
programmer where you don't really,
you're not hit by the success of it.
You're only hit by the failure of it,
you know, so immune, certain tech
immune, you take it, you don't get sick,
you're like, oh, I ain't, you know,
it's cool, you know? But yeah,
no, I, like I said,
a bunch of events back to the Ted talk
and so what am I going to show up to the
Ted talk? Coughing. Can't
take that chance. Yeah. Yeah.
I can't take the chance getting
happen. Stuffy nose. You know what,
what are you gonna do? No,
you can't do those things.
You've got to show up and have your a
game. Yeah. You know, shroom tech immune.
Yeah. And these are good
because these aren't like, um,
you know how, okay, so cruel.
Let's go krill oil where that works.
Your joints. But it's not like,
it's like a cortisone shot where,
you know,
you just don't feel it when you get off
it, you're jacked, you know, you're,
you're back to zero. It's like this is
stuff that like helps your body do it,
you know, that's the good part.
It's not, it's not a foreign,
horrible substance that you're
going to become reliant dependent.
Yeah man. It's still good. Um, and what,
okay. Yeah. They're all good. All of them.
And there's other stuff.
There's cool stuff to the almond.
It's like a three nut butter blend
good to him and tried to gourmet.
It's good, bad. It's too bad. That's
on you bro. Good. And um, yeah,
there's a lot of stuff on there.
It's protein powder and obviously
quality protein powder if you,
if you're into protein powder, um,
shroom tech for that. The preworkout,
that's the one, bro. If you're,
if you're lifting and doing hard workouts,
get to get the preworkout cause he's
not stimulants, not like, you know, so.
So I don't,
cause I work out early in the morning as
we know and I don't like working out on
an empty stomach on a full stomach.
So I work out on an empty stomach
in the morning. Good idea. But I,
and you told me that you might consider
this cheating because I will take it
pre's usually it's, yeah. Yeah. Yo,
look at you like I'm cheating.
Look at this guy, that button.
It's not cheating at all. But then he
also on top of that, I don't do it the,
I'll do it. If every heavy
hitter is coming to train, I'll,
I'll, I'll do it. It's a advantage.
I remember us rolling with,
I was on a 72 hour fast and I was
like almost at the end of it and I did
everything normal. I didn't, it
didn't change anything. I squatted,
I didn't pull ups, said
everything normal workout, surf.
Did you get to I was at the end of it
and I was rolling the big Eric. Um,
you know, judo, Eric and I said, I'm going
to tell you something when we get done.
So we rolled hard and it was no, it was
just putting the way we normally roll,
you know, and got after it
hard. And I said, and he said,
what were you going to tell
me? I said, yeah, I'm on a,
I'm on the tail end of a 72 hour
fast right now. And he's like,
well it didn't seem to affect
your performance. And I said, no,
I don't think it affects
your performance at all.
Just straight up to somebody.
And it got him a fuck.
I forget who it was. It
was a while ago, but,
and then I got them and you could tell
he was pissed. Who the hell is that?
They anyway, he said, oh one of
the first thing that you said.
Oh I'm fasting right now.
Yeah, I forget who it is.
That is actually why I didn't tell Eric.
Right.
Cause then it's just an
excuse. [inaudible] also and
also psychological warfare.
If I tell them, hey, I'm fascinated,
I'm in a fasted state, he might get all,
I get empowered, you know, I'm not going
to let that happen. Uh, Jujitsu is,
there's a, mine is on my knees to do
two going on. Even before you wrote,
when you clap the hands, give it that
little bump. That was an aggressive pump.
Remember that time or right after we
rolled and you said, hey, you know,
did you feel that?
I was like kind of getting tired
towards the end there and I said, no.
You're like, yeah cause it wasn't. I
feel proud you are of that right now.
That's like your, your best line to
me. Although that was a good one.
Good one. It was pretty
good. It's, it's, it's hard.
It's hard to get me tired at Jujitsu.
Yeah. You know what it usually,
it's not all conditioning too. I just, I
know how to conserve some energy. Yeah,
but he probably, you know her. You know
what? This is what, what part of it is,
if not a major part,
you can endure fatigue and tiredness
if you're enjoying what you're doing.
That's why for a lot of people
that treadmill, he's just hell.
Even though the treadmill
is not that hard,
it's like you're going at like a certain,
like a low percentage of output.
It's just so boring.
There's no like payoff in Jujitsu.
It's like its payoff upon payoff upon
payoff. You pass someone's guard.
Oh my gosh, they pass your guard, your
look what I've got a wage, my thing,
you know it's like this,
this intricate battle.
Meanwhile you're getting super tired.
I you get tired. No, no, I had to,
well me,
I'm in great shape and all that stuff.
You have made some incredible
strides though on two areas.
You used to gas out really,
really bad until,
until you started doing metcons
and your training in your,
in your non Judycki training used to
gas out really bad yet, number one.
Number two you used to get really cost
are phobic and not be able to handle that.
Yeah, and they were, they got to play
on the play off each other. I cured.
You have both those.
Once I realized you were
claustrophobic for awhile,
you're like test time. How
do you like this? Yeah.
And what's crazy is there's
a third element there is
because if you know you gas
quick
and then you get claustrophobic.
Now that's another enemy,
the gassing and the Claustrophobia,
that's another enemy. So I'm not just
going to you and you're doing it to me.
I'm going to get gas gassing customer.
So that makes me even more
like anxiety and like you said,
they're compounding problems
because the more tired you get,
the worst position you get into.
Now you're getting claustrophobic.
Panic can be more tired. Yeah. And then
let that happen one day, the next day.
What am, what am I scared of now?
It's the swamps of sadness, Bro.
All over again. Well you dug
your way out of that pretty good.
I think the metcon had a lot to
do with it. You know, you just,
what did you just mentally
eventually say like,
okay when Jocko gets side
control on me and holds me there,
I just need to relax and just sit there
and accept that I'm going to be here for
a little while.
Yeah.
And a big part of it cause
sometimes it start to get dizzy,
like for real coffee. It's not just the
feeling of, oh I'm just so claustrophobic.
And that's it.
I think it was like a for real classic
cause you start to get dizzy and you know,
like you're not like you're about to faint
but, but something like that, you know,
it was that, it was a good
addition. What am I, you know,
I used to get the guys and train with
them all like in a row and I do like 15
minutes with this guy and then 15
minutes of this guy and then 15 good go
through the platoons.
And um,
and there's one guy and he was super
claustrophobic and he would get so mad,
he'd be, you know, I'd hold him, you know,
I'd get across cider and get them out
and just not let him move from my chest
over his face. And he would just, you
know, and he would lose it, you know, and,
and you don't take, he'd be
tapping me like crazy. I'm
like, there's no submission.
What do you don't do that for me?
You can't tap when there's no submission.
We got me and then,
you know,
finally I'd tap them out and then let them
go and he'd be like, he'd be like, God,
you Kinda just stay off. Meaning get so
mad and just to kind of stop training.
I mean if you have like a dean did
that to me w back, back in the,
when I had, he was like mounted,
then I'd be like, and then I tap.
Oh Man. That's like man dean.
Actually it was funny yesterday.
Maybe the day. Yeah, it was yesterday.
The did you do the power was going out
like momentarily in the gym a few times.
Yeah. Well before the power started,
like it was going off for 10 seconds.
Certain lights though. Yeah, but
so it was killing the clock. Yes.
So we were going when the clock was still
running and he was doing that to me.
Right.
And when he tries to make
me claustrophobic or tries
to get reaction out of me,
I just go into like complete
detachment, mental shutdown. Not,
not mental shutdown in a negative
way, but mental shutdown. Like, okay,
I'm not going to show you any.
And so he's like,
like basically putting his
knuckle into my rib, he's mounted,
smothering me and rubbing his knuckle
into my ribs and I'm just laying there
like taking it and just thinking
about other things. And,
and actually I'm thinking
like when I get on top and,
and then the timer ran out and he kept
doing it and he kept doing it any to kept
doing it for like another 30 seconds.
And then he laughed and he jumped off.
So then we were going again and I,
I got him into got a good position,
right?
I got him in the arm lock and I'm
sitting there and he's already finished,
you know, if you don't believe
me, go watch him. Go again.
John Jay and Metamorris
and there's John Jay,
one of the best Jujitsu practitioners of
all time goes for a normal walk on Dean
Dean gets out of it.
So I'll go in for an arm lock on Dean
and the timer goes like at the end of the
round and
in and he's like, Oh God, here. He
goes, oh, because I didn't let go.
And he goes, he goes, I said,
you violated the Jujitsu Geneva
Conventions on the last round.
And he laughed and then I let them go.
But uh, you, no, it's all good then.
It's kind of what that is. Well
look, I tapping you don't let go.
That's a violation of the Geneva
Convention. Convention's yeah, it's true.
But you can't,
you can't be breaking those laws.
The metcon and getting into condition,
losing like little bit of weight or
whatever. Sure. It gets, in my case,
it got me in better shape
and you can go longer,
less classic flavor just in general.
But the bigger impact was that that's
not something I have to worry about
anymore.
Dealing with Ba when I get
tired and mentally you become,
you know what?
It feels like to be tired because I
don't think you knew what that felt like
before. It was hard to deal with. I would
say that's how it felt to me. Like what?
I'm like, Dang, I'm tired. I need to
not be tired. That's the goal now.
I don't care about getting tapped
out anymore. It's the tiredness is,
is really the fight that demon here,
not the topping up,
but once you go the Mecca nut,
like I said,
the metcon and just muscular
conditioning in general,
it'll sure it'll get you in shape.
But since you have to kind of do
it all the time for it to work,
like any exercise you're used to
it, that feeling, he comes comment,
what do you just knocked your lady
when you're mentally inoculated to, oh,
I'm out of breath. I'm not you.
What you used to think was,
I'm out of breath and I'm going to die.
How you think I'm out of breath
and that's okay. I'll recover. Yes.
Want to cover in some other position
and man, it makes Jujitsu way, funner,
way funner.
You can disclose nd two 10 minute rant,
you know with the thing and he's, and
he's going to hard and it was like, sure,
you're bull. You know it's a
good, good workout but it's, yeah,
it's just makes it way funner for
sure. But yeah, the point is there.
That's why you can endure tiredness
is when you're having a good time.
When those little payoff,
do you ever notice,
even if you don't really roll that how
you might be different? Actually no,
I'm sure you feel this when you go home
you feel like the heat radiating from
your body still.
You know,
even after you go home and like Dan
didn't really roll that hard cause it
doesn't feel like it's that hard
cause it was so fun, you know? Yeah.
Well I I real hard every single time.
It's
the genius behind it anyway.
If you want help the performance,
was that just a 14 or a 20 minute talk
about [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko.
Sure. Cool. Yeah,
a little bit of some digression but
these are all helpful things though.
They are very helpful on it.
That's just going to improve your
performance straight up. Indeed.
If you want to improve performance,
which we do, there's another one,
I'm going to go into it.
We got some time.
So I'm filling up water,
you know,
you know the big gallons of water or
five gallons. So go ahead, fill up.
I got four of them. So I put them in the
back of my car. In the back seat. Yeah.
So when I bring them from the water
filler thing to my car and grabbing them
both and I'm walking across the street.
You had to or you had four?
I had four but two at a time. I feel
too, cause it's two things, whatever.
So they're full. I'm walking across the
street to, you know, not the street,
the parking lot to my car to put them
in. And I'm like, this isn't even hard.
But they look kind of big,
you know. And I'm like,
this isn't even hard cause
it's like I'm not like stiff.
It's not like I'm warmed up
ready, don't get after it.
You know, I'm like, okay, but,
and you're walking there at handles so
it shouldn't be that hard for someone my
weight and whatever. So I get to the car
and I put them in, but I'm like, Hey,
I need more room to put the other two so
I don't just trying to lug them in all
perfect for,
I got to like stretch and put these,
you know they're five pound jugs.
What I see,
you got to stress these awkward position,
but I did it kind of no problem.
If I were in, I've been at times
where I'm not in that good a shape,
my joints are off bro. I would
to do, I would hurt myself.
That's how you hurt your back because
that is what I'm saying how people are,
they're back doing the dumb stuff because
they're not, they're not in good shape.
Yeah, and that's a lot of times that's
really what it is is because your just,
your body's not used to like
moving all of a sudden like that.
But if it is and you've
got the Krill oil going,
that's the kind of things you can do.
Almost like a superpower anyway.
If you want these amazing supplements.
No,
they're the best ones cause we all
know that on it.com/jocko 10% off.
Support Yourself.
Support everyone anyway.
And if you shop at Amazon is a
good way to support and you know,
you shop at Amazon. Oh
he knew, oh yeah, big
getting books, getting whatever.
Click through the website. Again,
this is just support. So go to Jocko,
podcast.com a little banner, Amazon,
Amazon banner over there on
the side. Um, click on that.
Then do your shopping can support that.
You don't think that's a big deal
and you're like, ah, you know what?
That's probably not that big of a deal.
I'm just going to go right to Amazon
without clicking through that.
That is cool to me that that's cool.
But if you do want to support,
but you still think that
that's not that big of a deal.
Maybe I'll support another way or
something like that, that that's cool,
but it's not true. That is a big
deal. Yeah, it's a small action.
So it may not seem like a bit of,
it's like I'll just click
through and that's kind of it.
But it's a big deal and it
doesn't cost you anything.
It doesn't cost you anything to second.
Ron's got some money that they want to
give to us. As long as you click through.
Yeah. They're like, they're basically,
the attitude is from Amazon is
that's a win win. They're like,
hey these shoppers are coming to buy
stuff from us through Jocko podcasts.
All right, cool. Cool. That's
take care of guys. Exactly right.
So it's like a circle triangle, three
people, three parties, triangle,
let's support. Yeah. Then
you get, you know your stuff.
If you've got Amazon prime two days
later, one day, sometimes same day anyway,
Amazon Click through.
That's a good way to support and then
you can subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already. Itunes, stitcher,
Google play and various others outlet
and somebody posted that you can,
if you have Alexa, do you know
what Alexa is? It's Amazon Echo.
It's Amazon name is Alexa.
And if you have that I do you do,
you know that you can say
Alexa play Jocko podcast and
then it says back to you,
you want to hear the show
Jocko cause they don't,
they think that podcasts isn't part
of the name because it's artificial
intelligence.
Gotcha.
So just you want to hear the show Jocko
when you say yes and then it says I'm
finding the latest episode and then it
plays. John podcast is kind of like, uh,
like uh, it'd be silly.
You want to watch uh,
Restrepo movie the song this,
but then the song is called love song
or something like this. Yeah. You know,
the song would probably be called destroy
planet earth. Right. In your case,
for sure. For sure. That's
something that, yeah, that thing,
that thing is kind of cool to start to
ask it. Do you have one? Okay. So ask him,
ask it. Well, what's one plus one there?
She's going to say the sum
of one plus one is two,
but I think you already knew
that. So they will, you know,
he knows the little things anyway.
Yeah, that's a good one. Anyway,
I subscribe to the podcast on
iTunes and all the various outlets.
If you're not in Thai tunes specifically
and on Youtube we do have a youtube
channel, put some videos on there,
constantly working on these videos.
Situation. Some take longer, you know,
more and more work and whatever time,
um, than others. But they're
out there. They're doing it.
Jocko mcnuggets small
little clips of the words,
the advice and philosophy.
Jocko also dad,
ted talk that I did,
she is on Youtube right now on the toe.
Gold Ted Jocko Willink. Ted Talk
or something like that. Yeah,
you'll get to see it. It's good.
I talked about uh, you know,
war and stuff like that.
A little concept called extreme ownership.
Nailed it.
It's actually good like that.
That's the one where you know how you got,
you got to condense it down obviously,
you know, like distill it down.
That was a good distillation.
Those good points.
12 minutes, not long. There you go. Yup.
Youtube. But yeah, I subscribe to the,
to the, you know, the youtube channel.
We've got one of those. I'm also,
Jack was a store called Jocko store Url
Jocko store.com if you're into shirts,
discipline equals freedom
and Twitter was like,
I like the Oji discipline equals freedom.
There's only one version of the desert,
but the thing is Julie,
Oh gee, the original,
the original discipline equals freedom.
Super simple to the point, if you will,
a good quality. I made sure that
they were good quality shirts.
I'm not the kind, you just give away at
the Ballpark, you know that kind of, yeah.
You used to talk about those shirts
that you give away at the ballpark.
You haven't mentioned that in awhile.
Yeah,
because that one's cool because Ooh,
free stuff,
but when you get home you don't wear
it. No, because this one sucks. Yeah,
it's not good. It's not wearable.
You know that one where you're like,
your friend gives you the free shirt
and they're like what I did for you and
then you're like [inaudible] wearing. It's
like it doesn't fit good and whatever.
These ones like fit good. They're
solid. In fact, this guy, Ryan,
I know he said it's my favorite shirt
to wear because it makes me look good.
Like it fits, you know, it's fucking dope.
I don't observe stuff like
anyway,
I may never make a made them.
I'm here to win.
Oh yeah. You don't care what you look
like, but yeah, they're good. Solid.
Look at them. I'm not saying by shirt.
Just go to the chocolate store.com.
Go there,
look at the shirts you like to shirt.
Do you want to represent you want to
support, get a shirt, get a rash guard.
Got some good reviews on the rash guard.
Multiple instances of
increasing performance and
results with the rash guard.
Proven and against Jockos philosophy.
Damon, they look good. You know,
if you care, you know that you
want to look good. Hey man,
there's that element
as well. Layers. Yeah.
I'm more concerned about the
performance in the looks. Yeah, man.
So I'll take that 19% minimum bonus.
Yeah.
You look good to go.
I guess actually that kind of thing.
Sure. Patches. The velcro lenses.
A regular kind too. Um, but
the velcro one with the,
the what do you call the
color right there. Regulation.
Yeah. The one you can wear.
I saw, um, shoot, I forget
his name on Twitter.
He showed me his patch like
collection to the Velcro, you know,
discipline equals freedom was all up in
there. It was good. Looked real good.
And this one is a big
one to support yourself.
Psychological warfare
is literal like support,
like a spot.
The feedback from everyone out
there on psychological warfare,
it's 100% of fat.
We'll do listen to the
track sugarcoated lies.
If you listen that track,
you could be in Krispy Kreme donuts after
not eating for three days and you will
go in there. You listened to that
track, you will not eat a donut.
You will not know. It's
true. It's absolutely true.
And the wake up thing to wake up
and I was going to say the wake up,
you will get out of bed. Yeah, because,
because you, this is the thing,
you know what's being told to you
is true. No, it's true. Yeah. Man.
You, you, part of your brain is
Tang. You know what? It's not true.
We just get up right now and
one donuts not gonna kill.
Actually it is going to kill you so
you're not going to eat it. Yeah.
Psychological warfare. That's
a good one. By the way.
I listened to it or listening
to yourself sometime. He will.
You know what I was kind of like,
why do I actually listen to this now?
Now I listened to it. Well, it,
it could actually in a way be more
effective for you because it's really you
talking to yourself, Shirley. Me. Yeah.
It's like you talking to
yourself like your brain.
It's like the voice in your head.
It's true and this is a good one.
Just like the Krill oil and
just like the on it stuff.
It's not like like get up and get
after it. Like it's not like, wait,
let me explain what it is.
It's these tracks on an album.
You can buy it from
iTunes and it's on Amazon.
Other resources to find it.
Yeah. Yeah. It's, it's every,
you can just purchase these MP three
tracks and you can play in your phone
before you're about to be,
when you're having moments of weakness,
you're going to skip the workout
cause you don't feel like it.
Are you going to skip,
you're going to mess up your diet
because you're doing old and it looks so
delicious or you want to
press snooze on the thing.
You can put it as your alarm or whatever.
You buy these tracks and there for
different situations and it'll give you a
little spot.
We'll say that chocolate will be there
to give you a little spot anyway.
Their mental, a mental spot. Yeah.
Psychological, psychological there.
They don't fight the urge
to be a slacker crush,
but it's good because it's not
like the get up and get out.
It's scares you out of bed so you'll
get out of bed. It's not that,
it's like psychological warfare. It tells
your mind to do things the certain way,
you know? So it's really, you're doing it
and it's like, it's not a kinetic strike.
It's psychological warfare, which
is actually more effective. Yeah.
Cause you're doing that. It's like
the cortisone shot versus the cruel.
We prefer to let our body do the work.
Yes,
exactly right.
And we prefer to let our mind do the work.
If you're getting out of bed cause
someone's yelling out of you. Okay,
well that's okay.
But it's better if it's you that gets
yourself out of bed because you use
psychological warfare on
yourself. Yup. Cause you did,
you did good things with the information
that you were presented with is good.
And I'll add, I'll give it to you.
Oh, I'm going to pat you on the back.
Pat On the back number. It was
psychological warfare was number one.
Is it stolen my nine on iTunes
since day one. Oh well hey, don't,
don't pat me on the back.
Thank you everyone that's gone in and
bought psychological or for, thank you.
Yeah. That's awesome. Yeah, fully.
But you gotta admit, it's like,
you know you did that thing, you know.
No, actually you got to admit that.
If no one wanted to hear it
and wanting to get after it,
then I would be Dan and myself.
We're like a little group of like,
this is a good, good thing
we're doing here. You know,
get everybody out of bed and stop
eating donuts. Thinking of good things.
If you want some Jocko white tea,
sure it's in stock.
It's on Amazon. If you're an
America, get it on Amazon.
If you're in a foreign country,
go to Ebay, parole resourcing.
It's the official listing. You can get
it there, do you? You already know what,
what the tea is going to do for you.
You already know that you are weak,
you will become strong.
You are stupid. You're going
to become smart. You are lazy.
You're going to become aggressive.
Just going to solve all your problems.
Do you know what? That's the side
effects because it also just tastes good.
So which ones are going to go
and I'll tell you what. Right now
we are assessing and likely going
to put Jocko white tea in cans.
Old, right? Like the drink an
energy drink doesn't help you.
Right? Right. It's tea. It's
wack. Yeah. This is boom.
Oh you're in seven 11 good
stuff like sugar, Caffeine,
candy, negativity, stimulator.
Boom. Here you go. Hmm.
Is there caffeine and Jocko white tea?
Yes, there is a little bit, a little bit,
but it's good for you actually a little
bit and Mike. Exactly. Thank you.
Echo micro dose. Not going to get
you all jittery. So Jocko white tea,
you can get it on Amazon when you're
on Amazon you can pick up the book.
Extreme ownership by me and my brother
Leif Babin and what's cool is our company
echelon front.
We work with a bunch of
different kinds of companies,
leadership and management consulting and
it's always cool to see and hear about
how the book spreads through those
companies. Somebody, you know,
somebody heard about it,
somebody heard me on Tim Ferriss or so
some of you heard me on Joe Rogan or
somebody you've heard me on this podcast
and it gets in there and a guy it
spreads.
It just spread.
You know a guy buys it for his team
and then he buys it for, you know,
the CEO gives them a gift and
the CEO buys it for everyone.
So it's really cool to see that.
And it's cool to see how it
helps companies align their
culture and align their
leadership teams. So go out,
get it for the people you work with,
give them the tools
to lead. And you know,
the deal is you make a little investment
getting the book. It's 20 bucks,
right? You give that book
to your key team members,
it's gonna make your life easier.
Return on investment, good to go.
And while you're doing that, you can
get this book, another book right here.
It's um,
it's called way of the warrior kid.
And this is the deal. This is what we
have to watch out for. Order it now.
Why order it now for not going to get it
until May 2nd. That's when it comes out.
Here's why. If we don't order
it now, it's going to happen.
The same thing that happened
with Jocko white tea,
the people that are printing is
going like, oh no one's ordering it.
So we're not going to, you know, we'll
print 12 copies the day it comes out.
We're going to get a lot of orders and
everyone's going to have to sit around
and wait for the thing to be printed.
So what we want to do is give them the
indication that yes, book is coming out.
We don't want to end up
with Jocko white tea style,
Barron Armageddon on our hands to
with the book and I'll tell you it is,
you know, it's a book. It's a
key. It's a kid's book admittedly,
but I'm going to tell you uncle Jake,
who's in the book,
who teaches his nephew
how to get after it.
Uncle Jake's got some lessons for
a very buddy about discipline,
about working out,
about overcoming fear,
about diet and exercise and life.
It's a book about life and know should I,
should I read?
How did you get the,
I know he's got a physical copy or a
physical copy that I'm holding in my hands
right now is called the
Galley and they give you,
it's so that you can see and make sure
and you can go through it and correct it
like a final answer, like a final
edit. And this one's pretty good.
Close. Give us a taste. So here we go.
So at this point, here's what's
going on. Um, at this point,
basically the kid mark,
he's like I said, he does know how
to do, he can't do any pull ups,
doesn't know his times tables.
He's getting picked on at school,
doesn't know how to swim. Guess
what? He's a 10 year old kid in life.
Life is hard. He's realizing that
he's bummed out. He's been sad.
His uncle Jake comes to live with him for
the summer. His uncle, his uncle Jake,
he used to be in the seal teams.
He's getting out so he can go to college.
But during the summer he's
living with his sister.
So now when Uncle Jake realizes
that mark as all these issues,
like I said, what does he say when mark
freaks out and cries and says, I go,
cause it's Jews. Uncle Jake says,
good, we can solve these problems.
And then he says, look, you
okay,
you're not really getting after it.
Do you?
Do you need to be? Instead of being
this kind of wimpy kid over here,
you need to be a warrior kid.
And mark sort of what's a warrior kid?
And so at this point
they're, they're talking about like,
do you actually know what a warrior is?
And I'll go back to the book right now.
So here's uncle Jake.
Do you even know what a warrior is?
Mark says yes.
I mean,
I guess I know a warrior is
someone who fights and wars, right?
And Uncle Jake says that is one part.
But what else?
I'm not sure what else.
So do you think that the only way
to be a warrior is to fight in wars?
And do you think that any one
who fights and wars is a warrior?
I guess so.
Okay.
Well,
you guessed wrong.
There was a lot more to being a warrior
that just being in a war warriors or
people that stand up for themselves,
they face challenges.
Warriors work hard to achieve goals.
They have the discipline to
overcome their weaknesses.
Warriors are people that constantly
try to test and improve themselves.
And yes,
war is the ultimate test.
But not all warriors go to war
and then Marxists.
But how can a kid be a warrior?
Okay.
And uncle mark says,
or uncle Jake says,
by doing everything I just said,
a normal kid doesn't push himself.
A warrior kid does. A normal kid doesn't
work to constantly improve himself.
A warrior kid does. I look at all these
problems you cried to me about yesterday.
A warrior kid wouldn't cry
about those problems or war.
Your kid would do something about
those problems and then mark says,
do what? Do what? Do whatever it takes.
Every problem you have can be overcome.
Every one of them you can't do pullups
you work out and get stronger and to you
can you don't know your
times tables you study.
Train your mind until you know them cold.
You can't swim.
You learn how you get picked on.
You learn how to fight.
Fight. I asked, yes. Fight. Just
like anything else in the world,
there are techniques to fighting,
like learning a sport and when you
know the techniques and practice them,
you can defend yourself from anyone.
You really think I could learn all that.
I know you can.
Like I told you last night,
I had to transform myself when I got
in the navy. I had to get stronger,
I had to learn to fight.
I even had to learn to learn,
but I did it and if I did it,
so can you,
do you want to,
do you want to overcome all these
challenges you face of course
and
then as a wrap up that conversation they
were out in the park when they're doing
that and mark says we walked through
the park and back to the house without
saying another word.
Something had already changed.
Sounds like we're about to get after it.
So yeah,
a fun book
might want to get after it and also on
top of that the book is coming out May
2nd that's cool. May 4th and fifth guess
what's going on. The muster right there.
Marriott Marquis in New York City.
Basically two months away from right now.
So sign up, book your
ticket, get your hotel room.
It's going to be awesome. Life's going
to be there. I'm going to be there.
Obviously leaves going to be there.
Jp is going to be there.
Echo is going to be there. Dave
Burke, newest member of echelon,
Front Marine Corps, boom,
fighter pilot, boom,
top gun, boom, top gun instructor. Yeah,
and by the way,
with all that,
he was on the ground in Ramadi with asking
you to bruiser do an operation after
operation after operation
as an Anglico team leader.
So the guys out there for their control,
he's coming on the podcast soon as well.
And as just like the first monster,
there's not going to be a backstage,
there's no green room that we're going
to be hiding in. We will be out front,
we will be talking to
you discussing things,
taking ownerships of the problems that
we all have and get them solved. So
we will see you
there@themusterextremeownership.com
and until we do see you
there,
we will see you on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and maybe we want to see you
on that Facebook. He Blah,
you'll be interacting with all of you.
Echo is at echocharles in I am at Jocko
Willink in to the military men and women
that are out there
right now in harm's way,
putting your life at risk
for our great nation.
Thank you all for our freedom
and to those that have fallen
for the cause of freedom.
We will never forget
for the police fighting crime and the
firefighters fighting fires and the rest
of the first responders out there.
Thanks to you all for keeping us safe
and to everyone else out there.
Thank you for listening and thank you for
supporting this podcast and thanks for
being here
with us,
you people that we hear from all the time,
from all over the world
in every walk of life.
Thank you for joining us
as we make our way through the world,
trying to extract every drop of blood
from this life by pushing forward every
day with everything that we've got,
all of us
and getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.